what have you got for us today eton yes
so today we're gonna be making dessert
pasta now dessert pasta actually dates
all the way back to italy during the
renaissance pasta was a luxury and so
they paired with other luxury goods like
sugar and cinnamon
stir pasta was born so how do we make it
so you're just going to grab yourselves
some
little wonton wrappers here you can grab
one from right here
we have wonton wrappers and we're just
going to take our little oh see i'm not
doing it wrong
oh your egg wash is right i found it oh
i have a whole set over here eitan so
take your egg wash and you're basically
just going to brush lightly the outside
of the wonton wrapper then just spoon in
about a teaspoon worth of chocolate
hazelnut spread and then
on the egg wash side yeah you can just
put it right in there yes
baby yes then take your fingers and just
seal it up just like that give the
little pinch pinch pinch and then as you
can see in front of us we already have
the mate on i'm oozing out the sides oh
man oh god oh
that looks like you may have put a
tablespoon
what was i supposed to put a teaspoon we
have these ones that are pre-formed i
don't know if that's safe to fry not
going to lie
i kind of want to test it yeah so we
have oil now preheats about 350 degrees
fahrenheit so add this into the oil and
those are just going to sizzle up and
crisp up get golden brown on the outside
now the chocolate hazelnut spread on the
inside is just gonna kind of melt and
get like gooey and melty and it just
results in a delicious little fry treat
it's kind of like a little donut meets a
dumpling meets pasta meets chocolate
mine's looking good it's it's getting
really nice and crispy slightly golden
yeah those are ready oh they are yeah
those are ready to go good watch i'll
just do this and voila
there you go
oh these are just
demi loons of
we're gonna make it rain with powdered
sugar
make it rain maybe get all of it all
over
make it rain
i made it rain yes and now
shall we give it a
try
oh cheers cheers yeah
oh wow
oh my god what
it's so good
this is good yeah beiton i love this
recipe thank you for always bringing
such inventive amazing things
if you're not already following atom
which i'm sure you are please check out
his instagram and tick tock i learned
more
i'm always bugging you like i learned so
much
through your content you are so amazing
you have a brand new book i'm so happy
for you it is just a joy to ride
alongside with you yes thank you and
thank you again for blurbing the book
out it comes out may 3rd all right eton
i love you thank you this is so
beautiful go to the drewburmershow.com
to get the full recipe and make it for
yourself and we'll be right back
[Music]